welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with the
uncertainty about the economy inflation
is pushing up the cost of food faster
than at any time since the late 1970s
the latest government data shows food
prices rose nearly 11 percent from last
year that's leaving more and more
americans worried about how to pay for
their next meal lana zach is here with
the solution some families are turning
to good morning lana good morning with
food prices so high an increasing number
of americans are leaning on their local
food bank for help i recently visited
one in baltimore and witnessed just how
essential they are to their clients
here's a bag for you to put your items
in even before the truck is fully
unloaded clients begin lining up to
receive food at the community center the
door in baltimore haven't been the
actual six
you can you can get sick today
the director of the door thomas smith
wilson estimates that of the hundred
people she sees in a day about 600 miles
are fed people coming through and
they're just not getting for their
families but they might have a sister or
brother that they're getting a little
bit extra for we have a lot of freezers
and refrigerators but we never need to
use them other than storing meats
after our distribution days
we've never had anything extra
with overheating
crystal jenkins is cooking for five
people including her youngest son who's
nine years old i feel blessed when i can
come back with something and help me
they're not hungry that's all i'm saying
they can't be hungry that's right the
price of food has outpaced most other
items that have been subject to high
inflation food prices have jumped 13.1
percent the biggest one-year increase
since 1979.
so
you got two bags at the food pantry
today at the door and you got one bag at
the grocery store for twenty dollars how
long will this food last you
because you're feeding five people yes
something like three days that's what
i'm counting on and then i'll be
back at the pantries again
again
for people dealing with food insecurity
the anxiety can be staggering
amonrot hedden a single mother of two
boys has seen her income as a food
server decrease as food costs rise so i
told my kid that we have to save more
money and then i even have to go to the
grocery in the early morning like six
seven in the morning to get the cheap
meat because they on sale cheap meat
from yesterday from the day before a lot
of energy is going into trying to figure
out how to save and still provide for
your family exactly yes i love
everything in my brain like okay what i
gonna do today what i gonna cook the
problem is compounded as more people are
asking for help resources are becoming
even more scarce
we used to get 700 boxes to distribute
to our organization to the people in our
community to other organizations right
now it's a hundred
you went from 700 to 100 yes to 100. but
the number of people you're serving is
increasing
yes
but we can't complain because something
is better than nothing jerry branch used
to run a food bank but the funding dried
up and so did his income as a senior
citizen he now finds himself a client in
the food line
was it hard for you to go to the other
side of the table
no not really because people that i
dealt with
you know was was just as equal or better
than i was i've never looked at it to
to down anyone or
i just never looked at it that way are
your social security checks enough
no
because they're not keeping up with
inflation no no no the rising cost of
food forcing tough choices
do you always have enough food
yes i pretty much always thank to the on
the door i always have enough food
before that we snuggling
when you were struggling to try and find
food bank options for your family did
you go hungry
yeah i go hungry but i feel like thank
god i met this i met the dog before i
get very very hungry thank god i still
work for the restaurant so at least i
get one meal to take home with me
as long as they're full i'm fine
and ammonrot told me that she would not
eat that meal she brought it home to her
kids 53 million americans turned to food
banks for help and according to feeding
america the issue of food insecurity
faces every single community in the
country and oftentimes these are working
poor people people who you know have one
or two jobs that's right
they're in there doing the best they can
and in almanrod's case she said tips
have gone down for her and she's a
server so she relies on tips to be able
to buy the food for her family but as
everybody is facing economic problems
she's seeing that people have been in
that case less able to provide
monizak thank you very much thank you